do you think if jfk lived we would not
have a cold war no absolutely not i and
we go into great depth on that in the
film and i urge you to see it because it
goes into all the issues around the
world kennedy was being very much an
anti-imperialist it turns out and many
people just don't understand that but
you have to look at all his policies in
middle east with nassar you've had a
relationship with sucarno and indonesia
with latin america he made a big effort
with the alliance for progress
and uh when africa above all with
lumumba he was very shocked at his death
and
tried to
defend
the the right the integrity of the
belgian congo with doug hammersjolt of
the u.n he made a big effort
unfortunately it didn't work out because
they were dog hammerjohn was killed and
then kennedy was killed and
congo descended into the chaos of joseph
mubutu's dictatorship
but kennedy was very active in terms of
as an irishman not as an englishman he
was an irishman
i say that because well we'll come back
to that because mr joe biden is an
irishman but it's a different kind of an
irishman they're both catholic irish but
kennedy really made an effort
to
change the imperialist mindset
that it still was very strong in america
and europe now lyndon johnson changed
back to the old policy and we were never
able to really
keep the talk going with the russians
briefly had it with carter
but then
brzezinski came in brzezinski was his
national security adviser he was put
there by rockefeller and brzezinski was
a poll he got revenge from the poland
poland has always been attacking russia
as far as i remember back to another
century i mean the two world wars that
occupied russia and so tragically
entry points were always through poland
and ukraine
uh
so uh brzezinski got his revenge and
carter ended up being an enemy of the
soviet union and
creating yet
as brzezinski took pride in it he
created the atmosphere of the trap for
the soviets to go into afghanistan in
79.
that trap was set he says he said in
1978
um
so
there was never except for brief moments
of periods of
daytime with the soviets
you